he is the host of the dandaka show on
wfn eye in indianapolis ESPN college
basketball analyst and he joins us on
the program how was your weekend Dan
five 250 I'm getting me too much I know
unbelievably good weekend went to a
wedding of my good friend Kevin customer
he was the best wedding I ever had then
right in the middle of the wedding boom
Andrew Luck retires and that made it
even better it was a fantastic weekend
okay what was your opinion on Andrew
Luck prior to this announcement on
Saturday uh he was never gonna be the
guy he was great quarterback you wanted
when you were down 14 I said this all
the time I mean I had Scouts tell me
whatever he was great but he's the guy
who got you down for a team with a dumb
past as he always said he always
admitted he always owned up to it I was
never going to be the guy was never
going to be what Payton or drew brees or
those guys that you know Payton used to
win a guy I got drafted Payton would
have him on the field throwing passes
summertime at the butler Bowl here or at
Zions real high school paper guys
running receiver routes off summer I
wasn't gonna be Andrew Luck he was never
gonna be the guy I mean he was really
never going to be and I said look people
argue with me I had one of your guys
Jason McIntyre went off on me because I
said ultimately I'd rather have Carson
Wentz then then Andrew Luck because look
when you're close and you see it you see
these things held on under the ball too
long I got that corrected once once
Wright came in last week made really bad
decisions early in the game great kid
great guy tough guy I played through a
lot of stuff but was never going to be
what what like all you know all you do
is watch and with and he was never gonna
be with the national media made him out
to be high but your reaction to him
walking away at this age
are you questioning his love for the
sport his toughness I wouldn't ever
question his toughness I did say that
and this is just me Dan I mean this may
not be you this may not be the Twitter
month but I grew up with a family of
teachers my dad worked as an iron
worker in the summer after being a
teacher cops I just me personally not
you I don't expect that I never want to
hear athletes professional athletes
being paid millions to play a sport that
we all love I never won him talk about
being tired I never talked about being
tired when I played in coach for Bob
Knight no matter how big a jackass you
want us it's just me I mean it doesn't
mean it's everybody now I would never
question Andrew Luck's toughness I would
never question Andrew Luck walking away
hey you want to walk away god bless you
but there are two sides to a damn and I
think it's fair to say you know the fans
here were sold a bill of goods by Andrew
Luck and the Colts and this has been
ongoing for years they have always
misled the public both Andrew all we can
go by is what they tell us what role
does hey look I'm ready to go he said I
can't I love this team this is after
2018 season I love this team I love this
group of guys all right we take you at
your word for that so people buy season
tickets hey when he gets hurt initially
in training camp if there was a game
tonight I'm playing three days ago Frank
Reich he's progressing well Andrew Luck
if I if the game was Monday I play
really good there's two sides everything
like I would never begrudge a guy in
football getting out with his health
ever good for him what don't we know
here Dan it feels like a lot and there's
a lot how did he hurt his shoulder
initially how did he how did he get this
ankle injury they never say there has
been a disconnect in this city between
the Colts PR and Colts fans and
everybody knows I don't expect national
people in knowing I expect national
people come at me and rip me but local
people know there has been lying Jim
Irsay no since 17 when I said Andrew
Luck will be ready for the first game
yeah he looks about the entire year Dan
there has been so much misdirection so
much distrust between Andrew Luck
because we can all go by what Andrew
Luck tells us Jim Irsay
the Colts PR and the fan base and I look
I'll expect people to understand that
and I get it people you know but I
question this like people why didn't
want a Davis get the same
I don't know respect for walking out
because of his mental health he got
killed but Andrew Luck walks out and
he's a hero I don't get it
I think if you if you're doing something
for your mental state of mind that is
awesome
absolutely awesome good for him because
in football you know there's better than
I did guys in football in this day and
age are trying to get out with their
health yeah
with a few bucks in the bank right and a
brand that they can sell and and you
know do whatever they want to do and
good for Andrew to do that but there are
two sides it is and the side from the
fans is based simply on the mistrust
there are a lot of things other things
flying about how he heard himself in
seventeen nobody's ever said you know it
wasn't in the game well what did you
hear huh
Oh everybody in town tell you did a
snowboard I mean I don't know if that's
true I mean everybody and Tommy I got
you know I don't know if you had these
guys but you know now people are saying
this I don't know I'm just telling you I
got five emails today there's two guys
that have always sent me information and
it's always interesting because it's
usually right like I'm not I'm not
breaking any news here from the from the
Indianapolis standpoint he'll everybody
in town has been told that I don't know
if that happens fact I would bet it
didn't but that's a big deal in here
honey hurt this last ankle might in the
game why do you think you got this
reaction from the national media what
reaction well they were upset you know
that you were you know kind of calling
out Andrew Luck you know the morning
show with ESPN with Trey Wingo and Mike
Golic we're calling you out yeah is
interesting I thought I mean I left West
Virginia that's what that was a violent
West Virginia occurred the president of
West Virginia threatened me and my then
wife my Ben wife stood up and said mr.
Hardesty what do you mean but you'll
destroy us and they wanted me to stop
uncovering all the crap they were doing
I thought that was a no that was a thing
of integrity not that I had to clean out
my backyard but that's fine I get it I
think that people are so in tuned and
have always been in tuned to like Andrew
Luck is this
I don't know this perfect human big and
he's a great dude what would you ask him
today if you got one question to ask
Andrew look at your shoulder well you're
not gonna tell you the truth well you
ask me what I want to know I want to
know when he made this truly made this
decision Dan because the timeline is
what I'm curious about let me tell you
something here's why I would say widget
why'd you hurt your shoulder because
everybody in town and everybody
nationally and rightfully so is saying
he's tired of rehab absolutely I get it
man I hate you know I've had five knee
surgeries to surgeries on my groin from
a torn thing
I mean rehab is terrible I totally get
what he's saying
by George shoulder in the first place
that's ain't because that leads you to
everything else that's what I would ask
in terms of when he made the decision
there are a lot of people that feel that
this decision the coach knew about a
long time ago yeah there are a lot of
people that feel that you know what
let's work through this we got season
ticket holders back in March because
Angela came out after the season how
excited he was about this coming year
and I watched him from 20 yards 20 30
yards away first day of training camp I
watched him go through the drills stood
right there if he was hurt and god bless
him then all of a sudden he's hurt what
it's an ankle no it's a calf no its calf
that's a cast
no it's an ankle no it's Jimmy Irsay
goes on with our guy Jeff Rickard says
no it's mo it's a ball what it's a bone
then it's a I said on the air how about
y'all just shut up how about y'all do
what Palecek does dan yeah and just shut
the hell up and say it's a lower leg
injury we'll deal with it and we'll
update you and that's what they finally
did but it's your issue more with the
Colts than with Andrew Luck the whole
thing dan look I don't expect national
media to understand like okay I'm in the
media if Mitchell true Brisky walked out
on the Bears tomorrow I'd go huh I
wouldn't know the story
I wouldn't know the backstory I wouldn't
know the history
the history in Indianapolis and anybody
has followed this will tell you there is
a distrust there has been I don't want
to say lying but there has been
misinformation continuous men the only
time the truth comes out if you want the
truth is with Jimmy or say goes up in
the air he's the gift that keeps giving
Big D he goes on the air the other day
and says let's mow and every fall all of
us are like what the hell is mo mo le
[ __ ] what small right and it's a bone
it's not a calf well Andrew Luck had
been telling us all along it's calf so
Chris Ballard who I absolutely love has
to arrange a press conference and say no
here's what it is you know and do all
this you know putting out fires
the only time Colts fans feel like Dan
would you agree with the only time Colts
fans feel like they're being honest with
us is what Jimmy are say spouts off yes
yes say you did save it I mean this
feels like you know there's a little bit
more to your feelings about lock you
says luck has a freaking ankle and a
freaking shoulder just tell us I made a
ton of money and I don't love the sport
luck is full of bleep and always has
been yes I agree with talks he smiles he
talks we and he tries to get out of the
press conference and and they've always
lied to us they've always he has he's
telling I'm ready to play it there's a
game I'll play tomorrow well that's not
true
he's always done that you know 7 and 17
they've always done that you don't kill
staying lose that you think you'll stay
in that room
I assume he's on the first plane to like
Prague or man you know you got married
in Prague you went to the Netherlands to
get I assume he'll be there a big soccer
game this week somewhere in the Premier
League I assume and good for him man
hey I'm telling you right now if I was
29 and I didn't like what I was doing
adios and that's exalt God do they look
I like sport people knew that people
Scouts very very respected people
questioned whether and that's not a bad
thing
nobody's saying that's a bad thing right
that's not a bad thing if you if you if
you've got other interests god bless you
if you can go make billions of dollars
and get out with your health at
Twentynine god bless you but me
personally I want to hear about being
tired when you're a professional athlete
I just don't you may you may say well
but there are people too and that's fine
and they may be tired I just know I
hereby because I can't imagine my dad or
my uncles should I don't the work 50
years in a mill he would have retired at
29 if he could no question they never
complained about it that's how I was
raised and people may not understand
that yeah but you would have called him
soft though if he retired at 29 right
get back in the mill if I would have
called that
uncle song I would have been beaten then
I would have been beaten and then bad
things would have happened to me when I
was on the ground see I get it and but
for us personally and indeed it's a gift
that keeps on giving there have fun this
afternoon there Dan thank you Dan that's
Dan dockage host of the dandaka show WUF
and i Indianapolis of course ESPN
college basketball analyst for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]